what um
what other guesses are there
that we know about that are like high
likelihood
as bio signatures in terms of life i
mean what are your other favorites
into so so we got phosphine but like
what uh
what else is a damn good signal to be uh
that you think about that we should be
looking for if we look at another
atmosphere
is there gases that come to mind are
there all sort of
possible bio signatures that we should
love equally
there's many so there's water we know
that's important for life as we know it
there's molecular oxygen
on earth that's probably the most robust
sign of life particularly combined with
small amounts of methane
and it's true that the majority of the
oxygen in our atmosphere is
a product of life and so if i was an
alien astronomer
and i saw earth's atmosphere i'm i would
get a nobel i think
on you know what would you notice i mean
this is really
i would be very excited about this about
the oxygen
about fighting 20 21 of oxygen
atmosphere that's very unusual so would
that be the most exciting thing to you
from an alien perspective about earth
in terms of detect like analyzing the
atmosphere like what are the
biosignatures of life on earth would you
say
in terms of the contents of the
atmosphere is oxygen high amount of
oxygen
pretty damn good sign i mean it's not as
good as the tv signals we've been
sending out
those those are slightly more robust
than oxygen oxygen on its own has false
positives for life so there's still ways
of making it
but it's it's a pretty robust sign of
life
in the context or atmosphere with the
radiation that the sun
produces our position in relation to the
sun
the other components of our atmosphere
the volcanic activity we have all of
that together
makes the 20 of oxygen extremely
robust sign of life but outside that
context you could still produce
oxygen without life but phosphine
although better in the sense of
it is much harder to make it has lower
false positives
still has some so i'm actually against
looking
for specific molecules unless we're
looking for like cfcs if we find cfcs
that's definitely aliens i feel
confident chlorofluorocarbons
and so you know if aliens had been
watching us they would be going oh
no cfcs i mean yeah
they're not gonna last long let's you
know everyone's writing their thesis on
the end of
the end of the earth and then we got
together we stopped using them
i like to think they're really proud of
us um you know they literally saw our
ozone hall shrinking
they've been watching it and they saw it
happening i think i'll be honest they're
more paying attention to the whole
nuclear thing
that's just i think they care it's not
going to bother them oh i mean worried
about us oh yes oh no worried about us
you